all right jenny
jenny where'd you grow up where are you
from originally i'm from colorado uh the
front range about an hour north of
denver
and tell me about your childhood you had
both your parents i did i did um and i
didn't i
i was an only child um
you know i like to joke that my parents
did it right the first time so they
didn't have to have any more kids but
really my grandparents lived with us my
mom's parents and um they were well my
grandma was sick
from the time i can remember um
she passed away from emphysema when i
was 10
and my grandpa was more like my dad than
my
than my real dad was
me and him kind of had a
strenuous or you know relationship you
know my mom
was this comforting loving mother but
she was also an alcoholic
[Music]
and i just remember when i was young
before i knew what that was um
my mom would be there one minute and
then you know at some point in time
every day
she was a different person and not
somebody i really cared to be around
um and
that was a continuous struggle my whole
life
up until um she got her dui when i was
about two weeks from having my first
child
so um
you know but she was always
kind of begging my dad to uh
tell me he loves me or remember my
birthday or
you know just tell me that like i was
good enough just the way i was you know
but i never really felt like that was
the case um
how would you describe your childhood
lonely
i think lonely would be the perfect word
i don't feel like i ever really
that like fit in anywhere you know what
i mean i
kind of was a floater you know um i
never had like a group or a click or
you know
real best friends you know like my mom
is my best friend now you know like
um
i wish i would have listened to her when
i was a kid when she said you know it's
more important to have a couple good
friends on one hand that you can count
rather than have everybody be your
friend you know so
um i pretty much lost touch with
everybody from school
you know
so
uh
i'm probably a little ashamed of where
my life went um
you know i was a stay-at-home mom of
three
i had my first kid at 20 years old got
married um
currently going through a divorce
um
you know i just kind of
i don't know i started to grow resentful
of my husband of my kids
never having time for myself
and i've always struggled with substance
abuse um
ever since i was young
um or addiction you know i had an eating
disorder that started at 11 when my dad
got me a personal trainer
he didn't realize that that was the
the way it was going to go you know he
thought he was being helpful and
it was more hurtful than anything uh
and once it made you obsess about your
yeah yeah and then and then um you know
i've been to rehab once
and um
you know as soon as i started not using
drugs um it went right back to
the food issue you know and
and
the gym issue i couldn't you know like i
used to go to the gym
and you know i'd eat 500 calories but
then i'd want to burn 800 calories you
know like
um
and i think the worst my eating addict
like my eating
issue got was when i was pregnant with
my third
child eve
i
had her
it'll be seven years ago on christmas
eve um
and uh
i was like 100 pounds i think when i
weighed in at my first appointment i
didn't even think that i could get
pregnant because i was you know
so unhealthy but
i did so i've got two girls and a boy um
eli turned 10 today and then zoe turns
12 next month and then eve turns
seven on increase on christmas eve so
just do you still have contact with your
kids um not really right now um i've
tried to go home and get sober multiple
times and i
always you know it always starts the you
know i smoke some meth then i go right
back to shooting heroin and then
when i came to california it was to get
sober ironically and then i found
fentanyl and
um
that was three years ago
fentanyl is your drug today uh yeah i
mean that's the one that i have to have
to be able to function like a normal
human being you know what i mean um and
you use others as well yeah yeah
but mostly speed and
and
fentanyl so
but um you know
so yeah i was like 20 25 the first time
i ever
tried speed i was working at a bar and
there was a lady there who
brought some to work i tried it fell in
love with it
three days later i was like i can't do
this anymore
i'd been up all weekend
my son fell and hit his head and we had
to take him to the hospital get stitches
and here i am you know strung out three
days like feel like [ __ ] you know like
um terrified of what that you know
looking like i'm you know in any way
under any substances you know
um and so then for another two and a
half years i was sober um
in that time i also quit drinking i had
a problem with that as well um
that was just you know that's the easy
easy option it's the most acceptable
uh used substance you know right
anywhere yep yep my kids used to call it
the sucker store we'll just put that
away i mean i mean if that doesn't say
that we were there probably more than we
should have been do you feel like the
eating disorder the alcoholism or the
drug abuse or just interchangeable
versions of the same thing yeah i think
it's just me trying to get control of my
life and
um
losing control
you know and like this is probably the
worst it's ever been like
i feel like
la has me by like a ball and chain you
know what i mean um
fentanyl is not as
you know used or um
it's not as easily accessible
in denver um
or in any other state so it's kind of
like we're stuck here you know
um it's like almost like i'm scared to
leave because
i don't know how i would be able to you
know i've never gotten sober since i
started using it so
um
yeah
so it's kind of like i feel like i'm you
know stuck here but yeah i just remember
that you know i was 27
i'm almost 28
and the second time i ever use speed um
a girlfriend of mine gave me it in a
syringe
and i wanted to try shooting up just one
time because i'd heard
how it was different than getting high
any other way you know what i mean it
was more intense more
um you know everything was better about
it and i'm always like go hard go 100
you know and i mean like
the fast you know the bigger the better
um
and so i
did a shot and
by monday i was buying my grandma's
you know diabetes needles at walgreens
you know like and uh
and you know after that
i tried to quit i told my husband what i
had been doing i think i told on myself
because i knew that i was gonna start
using again at some point and
then that way he would be able to pick
up on the cues of what was going on you
know because i was pretty good at hiding
um
hiding the issue you know
but um
you know it didn't help with the
depression with
you know me feeling like i'm alone you
know it was hard having kids at such a
young age to me 20 is like way too young
you know all my friends were going to
college and traveling the world and
getting married and
just you know doing all these crazy
awesome things and i was sitting at home
with you know
two kids um
and i just felt like
i hadn't done
what i was supposed to do in life i
didn't
you know what i mean i always thought i
was going to be
something other than just a mom you know
but now i realize
um
i realize how important it is
how that job really was like
amazing you know i um
yeah you know
you always wish for what you don't have
and then sometimes you know you realize
the grass isn't always greener on the
other side you know
but uh you know uh what do you say to
people that would say your
your judgment or your something is wrong
about your behavior thinking whatever
that you're abandoning your kids for
drugs
it's it's not the issue is it
no i mean
um
it's not the issue now i love my kids
more than anything in the world
but
it's a lot harder
it's a lot easier said than done when
when you have a substance or chemical
that
if you don't have it
you can't function you can't
sleep you you're vomiting you're
you know you're [ __ ] yourself you're
[ __ ]
got a you know what i mean like cold
sweats and and
body aches and and you're just
it's like the most
intense flu of your life like you can't
it it's hard to not to know that you
have you you can take something
and it's going to make it all go away
like right away you know what i mean
um
i haven't been able and you know not
having my kids here too is it's
it makes it harder to want to quit
you know what i mean they're kind of
like my driving force but didn't you
start using again when you had your kids
at home
yes um so that decision
yeah yeah so i mean i made that choice
i guess for some reason i never really
thought that like
you know i watched my friend the one who
gave me my first shot of speed um i
watched her lose her child and lose her
job and lose her car and her home and
for some reason i still never thought
that that would happen to me you know
what i mean i i don't know how to
explain it i don't know i mean our
brains
um our brains can lie
to us and tell us things that you know
like
i don't know what i was thinking i
wasn't thinking i was not using you know
my
my um frontal lobe very well you know
like rationalizing and and thinking
about how is this going to affect me
next week or
months from now was it that your mental
mental state was not what it should have
been at that moment absolutely that's
right
i'm just trying to yeah no depression is
um
it was my outlet it was what i had found
that took
all of the feelings that i had away and
you know it didn't really take them away
it just
kind of numbed them or
you know put them
pushed them way down deep so that i
didn't have to feel them anymore you
know um
and the euphoria of the drug made me
feel
okay you know
and uh
well it doesn't that doesn't last very
long you know
it goes from
good to bad real fast and you know
before i knew it i was in rehab
i got 90 days sober
i went to my graduation
um it was the day before thanksgiving
and my daughter's birthday
zoe's birthday was it was thanksgiving
of
19 2019
and i relapsed that night
once again my brain told me like i could
just go do a shot just one just to
celebrate you know like
to see it show that i did it you know
and like um and
you know not even a week later i was
kicked out
my husband found all of my [ __ ] and um
and i haven't been back since
my relapse date is december 1st it'll be
four years since i've been gone
so
it's hard
i'm not sure if my youngest daughter
would even recognize me if she saw me on
the street
you know she was two and a half when i
left and she's six now so
you know that's a really
that that age range is you know
you grow up a lot you know you don't
remember a lot from when you were two
um rather than when you were six you
know
so
i'm sure there's lots of shame and
yeah that's the hardest part i think is
when i go home and i see
how i've
sorry
how bad i've hurt my family you know
my parents
my mom got lung cancer
thank you
um
and of course i feel like i'm to blame
for that the stress that i put her under
i'm afraid that if i would have been
there like that you know she would have
never got cancer and got sick
um
but she's doing good now so that's good
she's had
biopsies every month just to
make sure that the cancer hasn't come
back and it hasn't
and she found out that was two years ago
she found out she had cancer on on my
daughter zoe's birthday the day before
thanksgiving
so
um that was really hard for me to handle
and the fact that i still didn't
still didn't go home and get my [ __ ]
together
i tried when i found out she was sick i
was in denver
i hadn't talked to her in probably six
months
my aunt called me and let me know how
she was sick and i needed to go home
because me and my mom are really close
and
she said you're gonna be what what keeps
her alive you know
like you guys are one and the same and
and she needs you to be there for her
and i still
i still [ __ ] up
you know
i don't know i i don't know what
i don't know
i guess you know people always say you
got to hit rock bottom but
i feel like i've hit that point more
than once in my life
um
it's almost like i feel comfortable
there i guess i don't know and fentanyl
is a very difficult drug to
yeah it's break away from it's harder
than heroin it's harder than meth it's
harder than
anything that you know what i mean is
it's
it's almost like oxygen you feel like
you have to have it to survive you know
um
it sucks
and it was like you know it was great
when i started it was like ten dollars a
day and i could be well and be fine you
know um in and out of all the re or the
overdoses that i had
um i mean i've overdosed
from the time i started heroin in
colorado to here
24 times
um and i'm talking like dead heart stop
like you know not breathing
lucky to be alive
some of them were intentional
um
the first one i can remember really well
um
i wasn't expecting to come back i was
almost angry when i woke up and saw
where i was you know
and i felt terrible because you know my
buddy from rehab it saved my life and
i was almost angry at him
you know it was a weird feeling to to
know that it's wrong to be mad but i was
angry
i i felt like it was just gonna be
easier if i disappeared you know
easier on my kids and my mom they
wouldn't have to worry anymore you know
but
but i'm still here so
must be a reason
yeah
[Music]
it's a good your story is a good glimpse
into how
how stuck in quicksand you are now yeah
it's not just common sense you certainly
seem intelligent enough to go oh no i
need to stop this and go back to my kids
it's not about that at all yeah
trust me i think about him every day
yeah and then you then you torture
yourself for
being in this situation right yeah i've
always been good at that
um
my mom used to even told me you know
she's like
we love you and forgive you and we want
you home it's it's not about that she
said jenny it's about you
learning to forgive yourself and she's
like and i'm scared that you might not
ever be able to do that and if you don't
it will kill you
you know
forgiving myself has always been the
hardest you know i think i think there's
some
wisdom in that
yep do you feel like you're in some ways
you know the role models you had
your mom was an alcoholic and
yeah
you know my my dad was you know he drank
too but he just didn't
um
i would say he had a problem with it but
um he wasn't uh like as sloppy
as my mom you know like my mom i
remember it was my senior year of high
school
the day before i graduated and i was
rushing her to the emergency room to get
her head put back stitched back together
you know because my dad had been
drinking too and
at the time i i wasn't drinking yet um
and so the fact that you were just
exposed to that as a child yeah kind of
i think it opens a door for maybe
in the worst case scenario and we're in
a bad situation when you're depressed or
when you're
not you know when you're in a weakened
state to
put yourself into a similar situation
yeah
yeah it's just it seems like um
you know
um substances have just always been
it's what you're familiar with yeah and
and um you know
like my mom and my aunt have both said
you know when my aunt called me and told
me my mom was sick you know she said
jenny i understand now why your mom
always
was coddled you and was so
you know um
you know always always protected you she
said you need to look up the term indigo
child she said you know you're an empath
and you always have been and you feel
like
the the pain and the weight of the world
is your own pain and that's the other
problem i have is that i grew up
always wondering why i
felt certain ways and didn't know why i
felt that way and it wasn't it was
because it wasn't really what i was
feeling it was what other people were
feeling i can walk into a room and not
even talk to somebody and know already
how they're feeling
you know and i would not i didn't
understand at a young age
why people would come to me and tell me
all their
problems and
and then leave feeling refreshed and i
would feel
like i was drained like you know
and so i took in everybody else's
pain to make them feel better you know
because i always was a people pleaser
you know
and i think that was
the biggest issue with me and my dad is
i just never
i never got that approval from him you
know that i wanted so badly
but you know i can't blame him for where
i'm at right now you know like
that's my choice to put a needle in my
arm you know not
i can't blame that on anybody you know
even though i know that he
feels like he's to blame for that
and now he's wearing that you know he's
got that burden on his shoulders
so
i guess i just really didn't realize
that
i was going to affect so many people
other than myself when i made that
choice
to use you know
you don't think about how you're going
to hurt everybody around you
you know yeah i mean your your intention
is not to hurt your children or abandon
them absolutely
absolutely this is not you know my kids
i never like you know they were always
fed and clean and they went to school
but you know i
gave them all ipads to play on you know
when i would want to go out and get high
they never saw me get high and never
high around them
so i think i'm you know the emotional um
aspect i was not there
like i should have been as a mother
um emotionally but i went through the
motions of all the other things i needed
to do getting him to school
you know
those kinds of things you know but um
i should have known when i i missed my
daughter's first recital at school
because i was waiting to pick up
some dope i should have known then that
like
it's only gonna get worse from here
i just didn't realize how bad it was
gonna get you know
so
all right jenny well thank you so much
for sharing your story yeah thank you i
wish you the best of luck i hope you get
things together and get back with your
kids somehow i'm working on it so i'm
inside now so that's good that's great
i've got a place to live yeah that's it
helps me out it's definitely helped a
lot
having a shower and a toilet it's
amazing
so thank you thank you very much
you